on this episode seth steps in for india
we're still trying to find her and we
answer a bunch of hi-ho questions
[Music]
you're back with the questions and i'm
back with the answers
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to episode 335
of the askgaryvee
show we're going old school
there is some variable differences seth
is now india uh stunwin is nowhere to be
seen but drock and sid are still here so
i feel cozy and i'm excited to do the
show all the questions today come from
the app hi-ho
where uh i've been really fascinated by
their platform i started really digging
into and then i decided to uh get some
advisory service and invest in it
a lot of you have been using it uh i
think it fits the way that people are
doing q a in the mobile world so i
decided to do an episode using that
format seth
you're laughing you're allowed to talk
on the show
you know i know you might be oh yeah
yeah
not sure what you just said but let's
get into the
[Music]
energy and focus on the show that are
important so how do you maintain
relationships but also say no to give
yourself the energy to do and pursue the
things that you really need to do this
is a great question i'm not great at no
ironically literally yesterday was
monday sunday night or monday
i started to feel a lot of pressure i
have which is kind of rare for me i have
series 2
v friends coming in april i have v-con
coming in may i have the nft drop for
the tickets to vcon which is the shift
we made so you're getting airdropped the
ticket we have an app for vcon that has
to work for people to get into the
stadium in minnesota
um i have a lot going on at vayner x
land um
our team who i'm hanging out with right
now in general is probably in an
interesting point of transition because
i've been incredibly passive by nature
with the gary vee content everyone's
trying to figure out our way
and there's 36 other things but
especially the be friends world there's
three to four significant things
technology wise that have to hit or the
whole thing breaks
and so
i was thinking about my calendar over
the next eight weeks and how bad i am at
saying no people need help i love karma
i love karma which means that you're
saying yes to a lot of things that don't
make sense
um and so a couple things one it's
incredibly easy to say no in the way
that i think you're asking the question
if i can flip for you on stage could you
offer me an internship no the reality is
if somebody's asking for something even
though it's an important relationship
no different than kind candor there's a
way to have compassionate explanatory
nose can i interview you on my podcast
no oh
no
but i'll make you a promise yeah you get
to 100 episodes and i'll do episode 101.
thank you
if drock who i'm very close to asks for
something i can be compassionate that he
wants to work on this project right now
i can explain to him that i'm in a real
mess these next eight to 12 weeks and
then say no that no is going to land a
lot better than if i'm just saying no i
think that what we miss in society a lot
is the nuanced energies and words needed
to deliver the package candor was a
struggle for me like i talked about in
12 and a half once i put the word kind
in front of it that package to the
delivery of the message allowed me to be
better at it compassionate empathetic
explanatory knows i think are incredibly
effective in the way that you're asking
the question hey gary i'm a real estate
agent i want to make a youtube channel
should i make one or three i want to
interview local business owners i want
to highlight what i'm doing just in my
process and i want to highlight the city
and all the features it has should i
make one channel or three answers one um
i really believe that i think
fragmentation we've had fragmentation
we've had two in the past fragmentation
is difficult especially with the way
that algorithms are going i do believe
that tick tock was a monumental change
in the social media landscape drock if
you can point up there up there drock
will show you
tumbler stock i invested in tumblr many
many many moons ago um because it was
built on the interest graph for
everybody in their mid to late 20s early
30s this is going to make sense to you
tumblr was special back in 2008 9 7 10
because it wasn't like who you followed
it was things you were interested in and
that's why i found tumblr to be
incredibly special and if i was making
videos like this back then i might have
even talked about tumblr as a
better concept than twitter and facebook
which might have seemed historically
wrong in the 2020s or 20 teens called
2010 to 2020 but the reason i jumped on
musically early show the clip of
musically stars on askgaryvee many years
ago on this episode we talk musically
with musically
celebs the reason i jumped on musically
early which later got bought but was
really in essence the american tick tock
and then there was an acquisition the
reason i always believed in tiktok was
because it was around interest
right your first video might get four
million views you have no followers um i
have 13 million followers on tick tock
but can put out a tick tock that gets
only 30 000 views the next one can get 2
million i always believed in that and
that's kind of where i see the world
going more and more you know i think
that because of that less destination
less going to someone's page but seeing
what's in someone's feed allows you to
have all three different subject matters
stick on your channel and i think that's
what we're gonna be seeing more and more
just like i used to embed
embed the youtube and viddler videos
from youtube and fiddler on
winelibrarytv.com because we hadn't been
used to going to social networks we went
to people's destination websites to
consume a video i think the same thing's
happening within the micro of social
media i think we now can have four or
five seven twelve different things
inside of our channels because the
algorithms are now going to be more
focused on what consumers are interested
in versus who they follow
we're sharp this morning sid we're sharp
garyvee what is one two or maybe even
three conversation techniques that you
use to try and get on the good side of
all the people that you're communicating
with not necessarily trying to get
something out of it but how do you just
go about
sharing that love with people from the
get-go you know brother it's not a
technique it's an intent
it i don't have one two or three
techniques i just have my intent my
intent is to bring value to the other
person thus every action comes from that
the actions the techniques the concepts
come from the intent not the reverse
so this one comes very natural to me
through my content that i've been
incredibly intellectually generous with
for 15 years to the interactions i have
with my team to the way i work with my
clients to everything that happens in my
life when you have the intent to do good
which by the way as a human being you're
not always going to deliver 100 on your
intent and that's a real reality but the
technique is at the core the seat of
your actual intent if you're actually
there sitting and talking to somebody
and you want to bring them value get on
the good side there's only one way to
get on the good side to be good
you like that one seth
like that
mic drop at the end
hey gary thank you so much for this
opportunity i'm a therapist and
spiritual coach here's my question me
too
i built up a
pretty sizable audience how do i
increase engagement um
i'm mostly on tech talk and instagram
thank you
uh
increasement of engagement comes from
non-scalable behaviors
let me say it one more time for the kids
in the back
increased engagement only comes from
non-scalable behaviors point number one
reply to every comment you get every
time for the rest of your life i did
that for the first five years of my
career before it became mathematically
impossible
point number two go on instagram and
tick tock live more often so you can
actually interact more point number
three do something like the askgaryvee
show where if people leave comments
extract them and do a show like this
which will then show people that you're
actually listening to their comments
which will engage that audience to
compel them to do more
engagement
engagement is the hardest thing to earn
engagement
is the best thing to earn engagement
takes work most people think the work is
done once you post the content to me
that's the beginning of the work process
on your way up
uh what's your advice if i'm interested
in something and i lose interest very
quickly um
when i've tried a bunch of things uh
especially that it stresses me out
because i feel like i'm never going to
find my true passion uh what would you
advise me on that thank you
it's a great question my my perspective
on this is it's no different than
kissing a bunch of frogs until you find
your prince
no different than dating or friendships
you know all of us at this point
watching this video have gone through
friendships and potentially
relationships and the reality is some
new kid moves in fourth grade you think
you're gonna be friends the first couple
days are good and then the third day she
or he shows you that they're not a nice
person and you walk away which is fine
no different than interests and passions
you know the reality is is that i went
skiing once back you know 15 years ago
and it was fine i kind of liked it i was
surprised i was decent by the third day
but it wasn't a passion of mine and it's
not something i want to allocate instead
of going garage sailing that's okay
you're also extremely young and the
reality is is that i wouldn't beat
yourself up or over judge yourself just
because you didn't fall in love with
cooking or being a yoga teacher or being
into concrete manufacturing the reality
is you still haven't found it that's
awesome there's nothing wrong with that
you're getting judged by people who've
settled
this is an incredibly important point in
our society
normally the people that will cast
judgment on someone who's still trying
to explore
are people who themselves settled
without exploring and are subconsciously
deploying misery loves company
just to give you context of what just
happened that just sucked the air out of
the room with my team behind this camera
because it's such a profound point that
i've not really made this articulately
and it's very important for all of you
if you continue to be fighting to find
your happiness and you find yourself
getting judgment from your inner circle
i promise you many of them just gave up
and they are envious and subconsciously
they're good these are your parents
these are your best friends these are
your siblings they're they're not
intending to be
mean tear you down stop you
conform you into settling like they did
but that's exactly what they're doing so
that there'd be no confusion
your inner circle
society is incredibly subconsciously
interested in you conforming
don't
hey gary paul maynard here real estate
photographer in colorado uh i what i'm
really curious about
is
how do you see real estate photography
fitting into the nft space
i find real estate photography like i
find everything else on earth falling
into the nft space this is my favorite
time right now we're in a very
interesting time in the nft space with
so much tension in the real world silly
things like nfts seem to you know slow
down plus there was an overpopulation of
junk so you have a supply and demand
scenario so we're starting to get that
next stage of nft land a nice year into
the phenomenon that has been popularized
nft conversation what we're seeing now
is people really starting to be a hair
more thoughtful people are really
starting to think i think we were in the
great era of february 2020 to excuse me
february 2021 to february 2022 i will
call that the great era of
collectibility only or 99 collectibility
with a hint of utility i think over the
next 24 to 48 months you'll see a shift
in the nft land where it will be
predominantly focusing on utility with a
hint of collectibility in a lot of ways
v friends for me was a 50 50. there was
a lot of utility
i can't believe i put that out in may of
last year and here we are in march of
this year and still
almost every project did not deliver on
as much real life
accessibility and utility and i'm
surprised by that but i'm not surprised
by that it's similar to the question
around how do we get engagement from our
communities the the thing that is so
powerful about nfts is it allows
somebody to put in the work right like i
just mentioned earlier that v con
stressing me out it's a big production
there's a lot of work into that i
understand why some people would just
rather make 10 000 squirrels with a
cigar in its mouth and call it a day but
the reality is is that photography real
estate is going to be utility with a
hint of collectibility so you're a real
estate photographer beautiful you're
going to take a bunch of photos of real
estate i assume houses homes inside
outside and you can sell that as a
collection if you get permission from
the homeowner maybe share it with the
homeowner the royalties and the upfront
sales but the reality is it is very
unlikely that the 8 billion people in
the world are going to be overly
compelled to collect photos of people's
homes there might be a small tiny group
of 8 000 people and that would be the
market that's beautiful but to get this
to a level of millions those photos are
going to need to represent utility so
for example if you launched a real
estate photography nft project which is
your photos around real estate but every
one of those photos was actually a
ticket to four one hour virtual zoom
lessons on how to become a real estate
photographer all of a sudden you're
going to have aspiring photographers who
are looking to do photography for their
life instead of working at an office
building a law firm a clerk a retail
anything else because they love
photography but they're practical
they're not ready to make the jump and
be an entrepreneur selling nft
photography or something else so their
practical job will be a real estate
photographer they may buy that utility
because they're actually interested in
notice how even call that they may buy
that utility they may buy that nft
because it represents the utility you
may then get fame built over time where
people may then start collecting your
stuff right like if i let me give you a
comp in 2006 if i decided to review wine
on pen and paper while i did wine
library tv
i would argue that today those reviews
on paper
given my popularity made sell on ebay
for 200 bucks a piece at the time they
were worthless
right if you think about the 4 000 that
i did so that's kind of how i think
about it i think a lot of nfts today
right now sit as very inexpensive on
open c soon to be coinbase and meta sit
as inexpensive less than 500 bucks less
than 300 bucks but are destined to
actually be collectible in nine years
right
the star wars figure that i just got in
the mail thank you seth green my greeto
an original package because i told him
in a business meeting the other night
that i loved greedo and it was my
favorite toy when i was a kid because he
was all green and i was a jets fan and
greedo was a star wars character and
those were my two passions in 1982
that greedo was a dollar ninety nine in
kmart and bradley's i remember today
that greedo that was sent to be graded
85 is hundreds if not thousands of
dollars i'll go look it up later but the
reality is it started off as a toy for
kids like me in 1982 at two dollars a
piece
today because of what star wars became
it's worth a lot more so is jackson
pollock so is andy warhol so are many
things many things start at low and then
go up right now we're in a place where
things start high and they're all going
to come down
greedo is my favorite burrito's my
favorite star wars character he's all
he's green on green like rick ross hi
gary this is denise from new jersey i
have a commercial jersey company here
and as much as
i post i feel a little almost guilty
with what's going on in the world
posting
how do you balance that
as far as being considerate and not
making it about you um
but still getting your business out
there thanks bye it's a tremendous
question and my team here knows because
a lot of them are newer and they got to
see it in real life this last weekend
you know as the tensions in ukraine and
russia
you know went higher it was me and my
team thread me and the v friends thread
that said slow down like this is just
not the time like you know as much as
like we're putting love into the world
and i do believe that the message that
we put out through the lens of business
but but the deeper message is incredibly
powerful during these times it's also
not very obvious to the 99 that are
watching this what i'm actually doing
and so it sits in the context of
entrepreneurial and business content
which i feel is inappropriate and then
you find your way like
i've cancelled three
three twitter spaces this week as syd
knows you know i did one because i felt
in that moment maybe it was the right
thing you go with your gut you do the
best you can it's back to the intent
thing i think there's been many times
that i slash
um vaynermedia's clients uh
from my dictation at the top have paused
content because it does feel tone deaf
you know it's really hard to say hey buy
my album when when we're on the
precipice of you know a real
war in europe which you know with a with
a nuclear state like it's it's tense um
at the same token living in constant
fear is not scalable either i've done a
lot of reading in the last month
ironically around
how people functioned during world war
ii
in places that the war was going on and
it's fascinating it's the human spirit
you try to like you can't just dwell 24
7 otherwise you're in a vegetal state
and so you find your way the fact that
you're even asking the question means
you shouldn't post
because it's already on your mind and
that that would be my answer to
everybody if it's even crossing your
mind maybe i shouldn't post then you
shouldn't
always go with that your intuition is
incredibly right
don't let your
uh logical
need for something at that moment take
over you know always lean into your
intuition if you're hesitant to post hey
garyvee my main question that i want to
ask is
how do you find and pursue your passion
after
like a big loss in your life say like a
family member or
a very emotionally impactful moment i'm
a big believer that the world is doing a
bad job and not allowing people to
grieve when there are events that i'm
assuming are happening here my friend
which i'm so sorry for
i don't think the world does a good job
on allowing to grieve for example you
would think me mr rah-rah positive go go
go
happy look on the bright side would be
the first person to overwhelm you when
something like that happens to be like
no it's okay they want you to keep going
they're looking down and they wouldn't
want you like
i feel like i on paper look exactly like
the person that would be at the
forefront of the no let's start the rest
of your life and they're looking down at
you and they love you and like which i
have those thoughts
comma
at 46 years old with the gray hairs my
belief
is that
we need to collectively as eight billion
people
create a better conversation around
grieving
um i really do uh i
for instance
have feel no pressure
on
getting back to work when i have a
moment like that happen in my life i
really don't
i will grieve
whether and i because i haven't been
through it it might take me an hour
because i could see that knowing my
chemicals and it could take me four
months and i can see that
because could and by the way let's all
call
a spade a spade
the circumstances
also are a major variable like how did
you lose someone is it a tragic
ridiculously unfortunate accident that's
going to hit you different than a long
drawn out illness like there's a million
ways to think this through did you have
time to reconcile it because it was a
drawn out illness or was that even more
challenging because it was like a cloud
for two years there's just so many
circum what was your relationship
with that person of course
like you know
people have parents and siblings and
spouses and children and loved ones but
i don't think anybody here is confused
we have different relationships with the
closest people in our lives that are
different than our
our you know our friends and family my
relationship with my mother couldn't be
more different than my dad's
relationship with his and so there's a
lot of variables that go into this um i
often find that regret
is a huge driver of how someone reacts
this is why i over push people to over
communicate with the people they love i
think a lot of us get into our patterns
it was easier for me to talk to my
parents when i had an hour commute from
new york to new jersey and wine library
for five years than it is today i think
about it daily like do well do i feel
good about how often i'm talking to the
people i love knowing that everyone has
an expiration date my friend the answer
to the question is
give yourself time to grieve it's just
okay it's the most profound there's only
there's two profound moments in life
the moment someone is born and the
moment that someone dies there's a lot
of interesting stuff in between weddings
and other things but those are that's it
at its core that's it and i think that
they should be understood and we should
go deeper into them and i think we have
to be
more supportive of grieving
and letting people go through it um
obviously you want to be supportive and
some people get into a spiral there's
people that are more positive by nature
there's people that are more negative so
you have to there's so many nuances to
this question but uh i i'm a big fan of
one thing like a big big fan i say it a
lot i think that people judge themselves
too much i just think all of you all of
you are beating yourself up too much
about
things
the things you're not or
you know my sister's back to work and
doing great why am i sitting in this
dark room sad about my dad because
that's how you feel and that's okay and
i think we need to have that combo hey
gary what are your tips for a fashion
brand besides from making content on
tick tock what else do you got first
thanks
first make four organic tick tocks a day
i mean it in the 15 years of my career
that i would call my modern career but
really my 25 year career actually
because it all came from email and
google adwords and all the things i did
at wine library when i didn't have a
penny to spend on marketing
this is all about underpriced attention
one of my recommendations the same
recommendations that always happen when
you make a consumer product whether it's
a coffee a phone
a sneaker or a fashion brand make a good
product and get people to know about it
so what do i think don't take shortcuts
on the product
make less quantity but make higher
quality like make a good product number
two get people to know about it
by far
and there's not even anything close
organic tick-tock is the greatest
opportunity for somebody that doesn't
have a million dollars to spend on
marketing the next best thing paid ads
on tick tock youtube shorts i'm very
passionate about i think is a real
opportunity for arbitrage so making
youtube shorts
networking you know whatever city you
live in hang out with other fashion
people
humans are the only other great moat
besides media arbitrage so one human can
change your life so if you're out at 2am
in berlin at the hot club uh because you
got yourself in there and you meet hans
and
he's the head of this that and the other
thing like one person can change your
life that's just real talk and so i
think that um that would be the other
thing i would think about networking
with real humans in real life especially
i think all of us are collectively pent
up for that in a postcoded world and i
think that should be on strategy
but but i'm not letting you get away
with it i would bet the farm that if i
looked at your social media
just the way you asked the question
there's no way you're doing four organic
tick tocks for your fashion brand a day
and the amount of people that
we've seen come through these doors aka
actual doors at vayner but more
importantly the dms and everything else
um are extraordinary so here's your
tick-tock
this is instagram can we does he even
have a tick-tock
find this brand yeah but like you know
the
one day ago
two days ago
two days ago
yeah i mean i'm just so over this
instagram like this looks like a
high-end fashion magazine photos
i i understand what you're trying to
convey from a quality standpoint i just
don't think people give a [ __ ]
i just don't think people give a [ __ ]
about every [ __ ] fashion brand's
instagram looking like [ __ ] vogue
from 1994 because that's what this is
and like [ __ ] like people want
engagement people want
other nuances like
between all the [ __ ] a-list
celebrities in the world all the wannabe
a-list celebrities and every [ __ ]
fashion brand instagram looks like a
magazine from the 80s like it's just not
interesting
like i'm i'm pumped for like a quick
little inspo but like
the ralph lauren model here that he's
executing on instagram is like
it like looks nice it's like okay this
is high-end i just don't think that
that's what's winning that's why
streetwear is really dominating high
fashion because there's a sensibility of
like some level of realness
like
i think we're fatigued i think
high-end fashion brands
biggest issue by a country mine mile is
the complete and utter lack of humility
and not taking themselves serious just
something can we get an off speed pitch
just one time
this guy has [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
right like
yeah i mean
you got to take tick-tock way more
serious and you've got to tone down
the elitism on instagram hi gary hi i've
been doing youtube videos uh for around
about four years and uh
under the name damn sam
and last night i was out and about and
uh somewhere
somebody asked me
for my picture um first time i've been
asked that that's awesome advice for
people coming up and asking you for your
paycheck
i love the show
i love you back brother my advice is to
to never ever ever i took two pictures
yesterday out in dinner
and the people that were with me
who are close it was the vcr group my
partner is in the five oh partner that's
how i have a freshman hat um i was out
with the vcr guys last night uh big
shout out to the people that went to the
miami events uh for fly fish club um
i took two photos
kind of like came while we were eating
dinner so it was like more i would say
skews a hair more towards interruption
but very sweet the best but like
definitely not like out about like
actually interruption style more but
again incredibly sweet both groups um
and the observation for kpon was
he was just so happy because he's like
man you still after all this time
are just so happy joyous he's like never
lose that and i'm like i won't it's back
to the first question inten or the third
question intent right
my my advice on how to deal with it is
to never let it not be flattering
never
ever
ever
let it not be flattering the fact that
another human being wants to go out of
their way of what they're up to at that
exact second to stop and take a picture
with you because you mean something to
them
that is
profound
and humbling
and
something that i could never understand
how
even even the
instances where i haven't loved the
toner tonality and i'm looking at drock
because he's been there a lot
i'm i still don't know how to convert
that into a negative you know more i'm
more compassionate empathetic of like i
hope that person's okay or everything's
good but
yeah
i like the person i was pushing you in
the back the other day yeah
very aggressive
drock almost got beat up
i don't i don't it happened early
because with wine library tv it's it
happened in 2006
right
and it had it was weird i think when it
first started happening where somebody
like where like somebody thought i was
cool was happening inside my wine store
so the context was weird it was like
within my own domain kind of like
so yeah i don't really recall
and i don't recall because
it kind of goes back to the ears thing
like because i didn't think i was
anything like it's like it doesn't
register yeah you still don't you don't
really hear a lot of that i don't think
so right
yeah
i just don't think you should
you know like i was saying to abby
yesterday and we were catching up about
something i was like it's hard for me to
hear the booing
because i don't hear the cheering i'm
very big on that
i think it really matters i think it
starts at a young age i've been spending
a lot of time on what we cheer for for
our children become their framework if
we cheer that they're so good looking
they start to find value in their looks
and become vulnerable in their 50s and
60s and 70s and 80s if we cheer for
their sports acumen and like they're
going to be a pro and then they're not
they're lost at 22.
here's the scary one if we cheer about
their grades
we teach them to conform to systems that
judge them every 90 days
that one scares me to no end i will
definitely be exploring that is the
first time you've heard it i'm in the
lab working on this one if we teach our
kids to do good every 90 days by the
subjective nature of a system
the current academic system and a
subjective notion of the teacher
deciding that to give them an a and a b
based on class participation we are
teaching them to conform to the system
and then they become those humans
so i think what we cheer for
my mom cheered for
two things no my mom cheered for one
thing and then the world cheered for
thing as a child
i was booed for my sports vacuum my sk
elastic vacuum and anything else my look
whatever and though my mom told me i was
the best looking at all time and then
and then
but my mom cheered when i was a nice kid
and the world cheered for me when i did
business when i saw lemonade and sports
cards the world told me i was good my
mom told me i was good when i was nice
to people not because of my grades and
i'm a 46 year old obnoxiously successful
businessman who pushes kindness
i don't think that's by accident i think
for all of us we need to think about as
managers as leaders and definitely as
parents what do you cheer for i think
vayner has a great culture because i'm
more often cheering
a c-suite or an svp for how they handle
the situation from an emotional
standpoint more than how much money they
brought in hey gary it's jadine i love
your stuff and i'm excited about hi ho
i'm new to this platform so thank you
for telling me about it quick quick
question what is the number one most
important thing when it comes to
branding thank you in advance for your
answer uh that's a great question
actually the number one most important
thing
when it comes to branding
that people can recall what it is and
the thing they feel makes them want to
be associated with it
when i say a brand
ready let's play on the other side
coca-cola
crest
the new york rangers
potato chips
uh adidas
when i just did that every single person
in the room and behind the camera
reacted as in i don't give a [ __ ] or yes
or i used to like it now i don't or
whatever it might be that's brand you
know what it is
and you have a feeling and obviously all
of our jobs that are building brands is
that feeling to be positive
which is why actions matter so much in
life because
you could do everything right for 20
years and have good sentiment and take
one misstep and then
lose that sentiment and i think
it's really fascinating right that whole
concept of reputation can be built takes
decades to build and can be lost in
seconds i think about that a lot i've
watched a lot of contemporaries or young
hustlers that are coming up the game
ruin their reputation by short-term
scams on nft land if the if the young
hustlers that are watching this
don't think that people like me are
paying attention to who's behind the
scams especially the ones that throw my
face on your [ __ ] project when i have
nothing to do with it because you
airdropped it into my wallet and then
you say i backed it you piece of [ __ ] to
try to trick people to give you money or
worse one that i saw yesterday when
you're doing an email phishing campaign
to donate to the ukraine and trying to
make pretend that i sent that email do
you understand what kind of piece of
[ __ ] you are
we're finding you we know who you are
and the a players in the business world
are talking behind your back and you
[ __ ] up your [ __ ] for a couple of
dollars
hey gary andy storch i've got a book
along with six v friends and i want to
get this out there in front of more
people to get more speaking gigs in
front of big companies how do i get the
book in front of more people and get
more of these gigs to build my brand and
make a bigger impact thanks the thing
you're thinking there andy is you're
thinking the book
properly you're thinking if i get the
book out there it will come and get me
the speaking gigs clearly with the way
you are talking the speaking gig is the
kpi i will tell you first of all i gotta
say six be friends thank you and boy am
i happy for you comma the answer to your
question is the following i think you're
playing the wrong strategic move i think
you're trying to create a proxy to make
the thing happen that you want i think
you play it a different way
do what i did this is literally what i
did when i decided i wanted to speak
i started looking up on google
conferences around web 2 social media
technology and business and then emailed
cold
the conferences and said that i'd be
willing to speak for free so if i'm you
instead of trying to get the book out
there with the hope that one out of
every 50 people that gets the book might
be involved in a conference and by the
way that's being kind it's probably one
in every 5 000 people or somehow being
involved in the in in a conference that
then will reach out to you because they
liked your book
i would go about it totally different go
to google
search business or whatever conferences
fit your genre so for everybody watching
here if you want to speak about pet care
well then just search pet care
conference enter i guarantee there's
results team show me that pop it up
right here let's see what happens search
right now i'm just curious um pet care
conference you can use your laptop
pet care conference um
and then just email them and say i would
like to speak for free i'll pay my way
get three or four did some show up
international grooming conference yeah
there you go
right there you go yeah there's one
right here in secaucus coming up the
international grooming conference right
you just go to their event and then you
just email them and say i would like to
speak at your conference and you know
i'll pay my way you get those three or
four right you
you get somebody to film it
your sister
you don't need drock your sister you
know like whomever and then you put that
on youtube and now you've got you've got
proof on on film as i like to say and so
uh that's what i would do my friend
all right that's the episode right yep
it is
that was really good
that was good right yeah we got to do
that
yeah there's some that was yesterday
oh that's right thank you i forgot about
that that's fun a little rusty thank you
sid uh the question of the day
why do you believe and i want every look
this is very important it's important to
answer the question today because i'm a
very simple animal i do very well
with back and forth i like ping pong if
i get a lot of answers to this question
in the youtube um
or in the instagram if you guys decide
to go along for him or i don't know how
long this was tic toc is now going long
to 10 minutes this is longer than that
thank you drock
mr captain damper uh you know
so and what about instagram we can put
this fully on instagram yeah good so if
if i get the answer to this question on
instagram and youtube we can 39 minutes
will fit on instagram
no no i want
how long is this rim last
good so if i get good answers to this
question on instagram and youtube then
we'll continue to do more askgaryvees so
here's the question
in the face of a constant barrage for me
over the last three years of talking
about making four tick tocks a day make
as many tick tocks a day seeing examples
of people
putting out tweets or coming up to me
like you i did the tick tock and my
why do you think
through a full hardcore
vulnerable and self-awareness lens why
do you think you are not making
two three four tick tocks a day when the
land grab is so obvious for you to have
success around your passion why do you
think you
are not doing it even though you've been
hearing it constantly and see other
people succeeding in the advice
this was the askgaryvee show we'll see
you next time
team if you like this show and you like
drock who just made me do this please
like share comment subscribe and
wherever the [ __ ] things pop up here